i'm just i'm imagining you like out in
public and you've got your magic wand
dangling from your belt and some kids
like are you a wizard you're like kind
of she's like what can you do and you're
like i can make myself less
nina what harry potter spell would be
the most useful in your everyday life
thanks for asking brian um
so i thought a lot about this one
because
there's a lot
like there's cleaning spells there's
healing spells but i went with the spell
that i think is best for the lazy
witch wizard or muggle with a wand which
is akio which is the summoning charm but
i would never ever ever get off my couch
ever again
i wouldn't do anything i wouldn't move
i wouldn't i would just constantly be
zooming stuff over to myself like snacks
and glasses of water and
my laptop oh my god but when you have to
have the glass already filled with water
for that to work
no there's another spill to spell to
fill it with water so
yeah but i'm saying you have to pick one
spot to pick one we're just picking one
kid i didn't i didn't know that it was
like one that we could only use i
thought it was like the most useful you
get one i'm still picking it
i'll think i'll spill some water i'll
figure it out
so you're going with
brian's whole uh web shooters uh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah from our other video
yeah i i'm just like i don't wanna i
don't want to get up and get stuff
i would probably leave my couch so like
yeah i would get leave my couch like
walk the dog or you know do stuff like
that but if i you know how sometimes you
like settle down on the couch or in bed
and you're like oh i feel so great and
then you're like i need that one thing
and it's over there now i have to get up
that i would love to eliminate that
feeling from my life i don't need that
energy
i i thought about picking that one too
if for no other reason then it's towards
the beginning on the harry potter wiki
of spells yes
[Laughter]
it does so i really considered it and i
was like let me put it in earlier
i didn't put more thought into it don't
make it seem like i just started at the
top i know you actually know what you're
talking about with harry potter with me
i was having a harry potter tattoo for
god's sake give me some credit you get
the credit you get thank you it's yours
tom what about you what would you have
picked
can we just take 10 minutes to try and
guess what you know harry potter tattoo
is you don't have to
there it is
yeah can you explain that tattoo it is
the stars from the corner of the books
well that is subtle and charming that's
a perfect tattoo thank you
good job
thanks anyway totally not what i would
have guessed but yeah
i don't want it not a deathly hallows
tattoo
i don't know if you guys remember that
because
it's kind of a mishmash of spells in the
books in the movies and you're not gonna
retain all of them they're also there's
just quickly they're not always the same
from book to movie either like sometimes
they change the names in the movie to
make it more like obvious about what it
is or whatever
yeah well there's a lot of discrepancy
canonical veracity of the yeah lego
harry potter video games
it's a dumpster nina yeah
there is a spell uh
i i can't remember if it's in the book
definitely in the movie that makes
snakes disappear
it's a specific get rid of snake spell
i i pulled it up v f
v perra evanesca
there's also a spell to make snakes
appear so uh a lot of man
yeah
situations
is just a vanishing spell they just put
vipera in front of it in the movie to
make it really obvious that that's what
he was doing
fantastic
so just so you know well now we all know
i'm really good
yeah wait so are you so you're saying
that there's a spell that just makes
stuff disappear yeah it's evanesco
do you have a girl whether or not it's a
snake yeah they could you could have
just said that but instead they were
like kids are stupid let's put viper in
front of it
that's a little bit of
latin in their kids love latin uh
interesting okay
anyway i don't run into a lot of snakes
but i feel like if i ever did that would
be a good one to have you just want to
have that one locked and loaded yeah
what if you're hiking and you encounter
a snake
great point what if you're at the mall
and there's one of those weird exotic
pet stores where
they're hiring at somebody who's
definitely
they're getting paid less than minimum
wage and all of the cages are made out
of the cheapest material possible and
yet somehow they still managed to get
their hands on like a 70-foot boa
constrictor yeah no one of those what if
you're at the zoo surrounded by
screaming sticky children and as a snake
escapes what do you do what if i am
oh i start chucking kids out i was gonna
say you want to actually just make
trouble at the zoo and just make all the
snakes disappear
oh that's the whole staff fired how did
you lose all these snakes everyone at
the reptile house gets gets the axe
because you made them sneak spanish
they're like oh no this just disappeared
this brings up an excellent point though
the harry potter universe seems to make
a very big deal out of three
unforgivable curses right
right you got your killing folks you get
your uh you're enslaving the minds of
men and then you're torturing people but
it seems like every spell
in this universe could potentially be
pretty unforgivable right like
like there's there's terrible stuff that
you could do with any of these right
speaking to that point is is brian with
his apparent lust for uh for getting zoo
employees fired i hate him for kicks
apparently get rid of all of them yeah
all right
don't ask me why they know why
stop feeding pandas they know what they
did to me i didn't say it brian said it
i'm not taking the blame the heat for
this one in the comments
sure take that zoo
um anyway that's uh that's what i got
the big big zoo industry brian let's get
a little glimpse into the the mind that
brought us fire all zookeepers what
would you do if you were my pick
was called it didn't have any fancy
latin they didn't give us that it's
called the cheering charm
it makes you happy it does
how useful is that
drug drug free depression cure
well think about it you'd have to use it
every second of every day for that
well it lasts longer than a second but
i'm saying like also it makes doesn't it
make people like my recollection from
the books is it makes people like giggle
uncontrollably only if you do it wrong
you're describing the opening of joker
where he hands only that card is like i
laugh too much something's wrong with me
i see there's a charm there's a magic
spell that makes
you
happy
it makes you feel elated
and maybe yeah you're gonna laugh i live
in minnesota
it's winter here
nine months out of the year oh i thought
you meant it's under there now i was
like it's winter here now no um but i'm
saying like you can go a long time
without kind of you know
some the days get dark and cold
really cold who wouldn't want to just
kind of wave a wand and say oh
i feel happy now that's right
the whole
magical world at your fingertips and you
picked a thing that could be cured by a
seasonal effective depression
like lamp little sprinkle of an ssri
really i just i just well look i'm
saying this is this i don't need a
prescription for this i don't have to go
make a doctor's appointment to use that
you have like a young kid and you
wouldn't even pick the one where you
just clean up stuff
uh i didn't i didn't get that far in the
harry potter
okay i'm thinking i'm seeing what
happened you got as far as see and you
stopped
how far down on the page is cleaning
see are we all happier
you're welcome and
you've given us so much to think on here
you know i just i'm imagining you like
out in public and you've got your magic
wand dangling from your belt and some
kid's like are you a wizard you're like
kind of she's like what can you do and
you're like i can make myself less
[Laughter]
oh my god
this has been such a dark exploration of
our minds
we broke brian
i'm not crying
you need a cheering job
it's gonna be so much more impressive in
a couple of years
but right now i probably played pretty
stupid
oh time for the old magic
being an adult is hard
yeah it's a tough world out there don't
you wish don't i mean look don't we all
feel pretty good
as though we've all been cheered but i
feel really great if i could summon a
sweatshirt right now but you know each
to his own i guess that's fair too i
guess there's a lot of paths to
happiness
not having any snakes in your room
that makes you happy knowing that guys
if you ever see a snake
not for long buddy thanks for watching
please hit like and subscribe so you
don't miss a single video